The joe rogan experience.
A lot of very weird people out there.
There's a lot of very
weird people here in la.
Oh,
the weirdest.
This is the weirdest spot because this
is the spot where they think they're
going to finally get that attention
that they deserve and sexually weird.
There's a lot of weird sex in it.
And in La.
I on here,
man.
Come on.
Me Talking to my,
when you're doing well,
I'm in a relationship now,
but uh,
I was uh,
very much,
uh,
I'll,
I'll tell you,
I got some good stories.
Okay,
please.
This is,
this is a pretty good one.
Oh,
well I want to tell you the,
okay,
well the one,
when I was starting to hit bottom,
I've gone,
I've had some issues with sex,
but one real bad story was I,
there was a girl,
I was,
I went to this clothing store and I
used to beat really in a big girl.
It's like very big girls.
How big,
I mean,
as big as you could muster.
Hundred plus.
I mean,
I was into it.
All right.
I like a thick girl anyway.
Right?
But my girl now is not very small,
but the deal with it,
no,
I love her and she's great.
She's hot.
If we were in ski clothes,
so it does,
I'll feed her a lot.
You know those relationships
where there's a feeder,
do you know about that?
No guys that are real.
This is like where,
where the fat thing he go.
It goes beyond just like a,
like I think it's hot and
even to like a like a fetish.
So there'll be a guy like me,
like a skinny kind of weekly and guy
that's like bringing his fat girlfriend
like Twinkies and and Ho Hos and roast
beef and stuffing and just be like,
here honey,
you keep eating.
And she gets bigger and bigger.
So there's like a feed or,
and then there's like a big woman that
just eventually I guess grows and grows
and grows and his erection grows
with her or something like that.
Whoa.
What know this relationship is defined.
Like when you say
there's a type like yeah,
this is defined like websites
where they talk about this.
Yeah,
I mean you could look that up.
I mean that's that I'm not,
but is it like a,
is there a community?
Uh,
well,
yeah.
I don't know if there's a community
because they have to bring,
they have to get,
it's hard to get that many cranes
to bring people to the meetings.
And what,
I mean like an online community
where this is all discussed.
I'm sure.
Yeah.
No,
this is a real thing.
Have you heard of it?
I've never heard of that.
Have you been trying
this with your new girl?
No.
No,
no,
no I'm not,
it was never like that for me.
I mean this is like a weird psychological,
like I'm going to bring you food.
It's being dominated by
one person that's passive.
I think the,
you know,
the,
the dominatrix in this case doesn't even
have to do anything but sit around and
eat,
you know?
That's interesting.
But anyway,
I don't know why I even brought that up.
That's weird sex stuff.
So this person was,
was big and I went to the store,
she was the,
she was the parking
attendant at the store.
And this is like well into comedy,
so I'm okay on some
level of public figure.
I mean,
not like a huge public figure,
but enough that it's like,
I shouldn't be like at random approaching,
maybe I should,
who knows.
Anyway,
this girl,
she was bigger and she was a parking lot
attendant at this store and I somehow
started talking to her and got her phone
number and then sort of texting with
her and I,
this is,
so I remember I had a show
that night in Orange County.
I was at a,
um,
a comedy show at Uc Irvine and I brought
my friend Jacob Jacob sear off down to
the,
down to the show.
And,
uh,
and she was texting with me while I was
at the show in Orange County and was
like,
Oh,
you should've said something.
You know,
I would have sucked your
dick in the parking lot.
And I was like,
oh,
really?
All activated,
like a little Dick Getting
hard like that Rob Ford Guy,
you know,
and uh,
and she's like,
yeah,
I mean,
you know what,
you come by my house tonight.
I'll suck your dick tonight.
And I was like,
I was like,
where do you live?
And she's like,
Compton and I,
and I started doing the math and I'm like,
okay,
Orange County,
if I'm driving back to
my home in silver lake,
Compton is sort of in
a weird way on the way.
So I fucking get rid of Jacob,
you know,
I go,
I say to some other comic like,
can you please give it
a take a boat ride home?
I've got an erection right now.
And uh,
like,
uh,
okay.
Like I don't tell anybody what's going on.
My friend,
my good friend Jacob was like,
why are you sloughing me off on this?
Stranger is going to give him a ride home.
I like Ed.
He's got some business to take care of it.
It's like,
it's 1130 at night.
What?
But he's a pervert too.
So I'm driving,
I pull off the exit and Compton where
this girl says she's going to suck my Dick
and uh,
and I start driving through content and
it's getting weirder and weirder and
worse and worse the further I go and
I keep texting her and she's like,
keep going,
keep going.
And I pulled down this alley and,
and it's like an abandoned
alley and it's like,
it's like you want to talk about
having two different brains,
you know what I mean?
Like I knew my brain,
my good brain,
my big brain was telling me
like your going to be murdered.
This is a situation where you're,
I'm driving down an alley.
There's an empty field on one side,
there's like tract
housing on the other side.
Like it's,
there's no street lights.
She's,
and she keeps going,
keep going,
keep going.
I'm at the end of the,
at the end of this alley
I'm waiting for you.
Keep going.
I just know I'm going to get there.
Her brothers are going to come out,
surround the car.
I'm dead.
My car's dead.
And I keep driving forward because I
have this other brain that's like this,
a little Ayp Bonobo
brain that's going like,
it's the end of this road.
There's a blow job.
Keep doing weights.
I swear you couldn't.
There is no place in la that is more
well suited to murder a white person then
this alley.
Wow.
So how's it go down?
She comes outside,
take a deep breath.
She gets in the car and she
gives me a blow job and I drive.
Wow.
When you came,
was it like the most
like sneaky coming ever?
Like,
oh,
I can't be like [inaudible]
the ignition was already on.
Oh,
the other crazy thing is she lives in,
she lives in Compton.
One of the first things she says before
she starts giving me head is uh Oh yeah,
I love sucking Dick.
I'll suck anybody's dick except for,
and then she just drops
in and bomb like a heart.
And I'm like,
you live in Compton.
And my other,
again,
two brains,
my brain is like,
don't comment on the racism.
Don't comment on the racism.
Come on.
She's about to give you a blowjob.
Don't even,
and I didn't,
I focused,
I focused up.
Oh,
I got through it.
Wow.
Was that the last time you saw her?
Yeah,
it was the last time I saw it.
Did you change your phone number?
I,
I wait,
I'm lying to you.
No,
I changed my,
I erased the phone number,
uh,
and told her I have a girlfriend now.
It didn't have a girlfriend.
I have a girlfriend now,
raised her phone number and then I like
maybe six months later I drove by that
place again.
God,
her phone number again,
started texting with her and then
I've raced her phone number and never,
I never went back.
She was,
she was big.
She was like two to 50 probably.
You been with a lot of big girls.
Uh,
yeah.
Have you ever had any kind of cleaning
problems where they smell more like poop
or does that get you like a
bigger boner when you smell that?
Cause I mean they don't smell the best.
It's a serious question though.
It seems like a serious question.
He's throwing Ibogaine
at me as he asks for it.
Um,
no,
I mean,
you know people fat people shower.
Yeah.
Okay.
But I hear what you're saying.
They can get all those nooks and crannies
if you're talking about the big is not
that big bro.
Yeah.
I mean I'm talking about like
five hundreds Ralphie may size.
I have fucked her off.
He May.
May.
Is Music Good?
Got To fuck.
Yeah.
Betty is those guys.
There was another girl when I first
moved to town that she was like,
uh,
she was like a kind of,
she was real intense.
Speaking of power dynamics.
She was,
she's a kind of girl.
She kept going like put
your cigarette out on me,
put your cigarette out.
And I was like,
I,
I can't,
I don't,
I don't think I can do that.
And she would be like,
she was very aggressive and pain oriented
and she was biting me and like biting
my Dick and biting my balls.
Oh God damn it.
But it was also hot,
but also I didn't like the
biting part and be like,
Oh stop out.
And uh,
at one point she had them all
Jewish like that now stop.
And at one point she looks down,
she's like going down.
I mean she stops and she goes,
what is that?
And you know the kind of,
what is that the way you would say like
if you were going down on a girl and you
saw like a,
some sort of sore or something.
And I'm like,
what?
And I look and there is a contusion,
like a straight up like bubbled blood
blister on my scrotum from her biting you
from her by,
I say you fucking did that.
And she's,
and then afterwards she was like,
that was great,
we should do it again.
And I texted her,
I was like,
I don't know,
I think you maybe play a
little too rough for me.
And she goes,
uh,
okay.
She's like,
no,
like all dial it back.
No like it's all,
let's try.
It was just like,
if you can't fucking ride the
dragon with the scales that I have,
then get off.
God Damn Man,
Jesus Christ.
I got more.
Have you ever had the color like
the next day where you're like,
why is my back and you just look
on your back and he's just like,
Oh yeah,
I've had that.
But that's sort of normal.
That's girls just getting caught
up in the throes of passion.
That's tie.
That seems good.
That's why I ramping down your skirt.
I other,
I had,
I,
I've had sexual,
I don't know if you've,
you don't seem like you've had,
because you seem like you've been having
like fun sex experiences your whole
life.
What makes you say that?
Like,
you know,
you're like good looking and you've been,
you've been famous for
a long time and it's,
you feel like,
you think there's only fun sex that way.
Know what I feel like.
I feel like you're the type of dude
that likes to have sex only with good
looking women.
Yeah,
I'm crazy like that.
Yeah.
You're average,
a sexual deviant and that way,
no,
but there's like for me,
I used to get off on like hooking up
with people that were not as a truck.
I was Han purpose.
It was hot,
you know,
I was fine to them.
Yeah.
And I would find a objective
attractiveness in people
that weren't objectively
attractive.
Does that make sense?
Yeah.
So,
okay.
So what we were talking about earlier,
like that's your,
your kink.
So like the drug thing,
whatever led you to be an impulsive
drug person led you for awhile to be an
impro impulsive sex person.
So wasn't even almost a
natural sort of attraction.
Like,
wow,
that's a pretty girl.
She likes me.
I like her.
I love her personality.
You didn't even like her personality.
She's talking about dropping embalmed
Nigga dicks.
She's,
you'll like us still.
There's something about you that's hot.
Interestingly enough though,
I actually have one.
Oh yeah.
It's real big and black and
where it was a shocker to her,
she was really fun.
But
look where I live.
Uh,
yeah,
no,
for sure.
That became the thing.
And it also is very compartmentalized.
I would be like in a store.
I remember one instance in particular,
I was at this store at like two
o'clock in the morning shopping for,
I was at Safeway getting some groceries
and this woman walked around the corner
and she was big and in the way
that I liked and I started.
Did you ever get like,
have you ever gotten so
horny you start getting cold?
Yeah.
You know what I mean?
Little shivery yes.
I,
I'm not even flirting with this woman.
She just a woman's shopping at two in
the morning for fucking cheese whiz or
whatever.
And I'm like,
I got to figure out a way to,
can you imagine if I walked up to her
with a shivering like a two in the
morning?
Like,
Hey,
how are you?
There's no way she's fucking mate.
That's go so crazy.
Cause it's just cause
she's big or something.
Yeah.
Something.
What else could it be if
it wasn't a big thing?
No,
I guess you're right.
It's a big,
I mean it must be right.
That's when it would
get the most pronounced.
It was pretty intense.
Wow.
That's amazing.
I've had sex where I lie,
sold after the woman left because
he thought I was rational.
You thought it was rational?
No,
cause I know she was like
scratching this area of her body.
When she left,
I was like freaked out so hard
that I went into my bathroom.
I started life solving my legs like
shape and then dish soap and then salt.
And the next day I,
speaking of 12 step meetings,
I went to my first and only
sex addicts anonymous meeting.
I was just like,
something's got to change.
To look at your face was awesome.
You know,
there's,
there's no,
there's very little way for you to
convince yourself that you're just like a
young man swinging around,
having a good time,
engaging in the regular
sexuality of all human beings.
When you're spraying Lysol.
I'm
like,
how do you,
oh,
oh that's awesome.
So I went and one of
the things about s sex,
well,
the first thing I realized when I got
to a sex addicts anonymous meeting is I
may have a problem or something.
I may have a compulsive sexuality,
but I don't have what these people have.
I mean,
there's something else
that they're talking about.
What were they talking about?
They were talking about,
I'll look,
I'll start looking at pornography at
4:00 PM and then all of a sudden the sun
will be coming up.
Whoa.
And I was like,
oh.
Or like I,
I had a home,
but I took all of my money
and spent it on prostitutes,
you know,
that kind of thing.
And Wow.
It was very intense.
It was stuff that I did
not really fully relate to.
Okay.